hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to reddit's 5050
challenge now some of you may not know
what this is about and consider yourself
lucky but if you don't i'll explain it
very quickly this is
true 50 50 mode on the 50 50 subreddit
which means that of the two options that
are presented to me
like cute charmy b or dr robotnik rule
that means if i click on this link i
will get one
or the other but okay let's try this
i don't know what i'm gonna see ah
it's dr robotnik
oh my god why why would someone draw
that
why would someone put time and effort
into drawing that
why would they do that what couldn't
have gotten cute charming
do you get it do you get it do you get
the idea yeah it's one or the other and
right now i'm only getting one
okay here we go i'm both i'm stalling
for time because i don't want to keep
going but here we go
a video of my dog rolling around in some
grass that sounds lovely
or my horrific sunburn that doesn't
sound lovely it's a doggy huh
thank goodness oh thank goodness look at
the doggy
oh look at you oh look at
you oh what a cutie what a cutie
patootie
what a cute oh look at that whack
get into this so badly purge dr robotnik
from my brain
oh okay oof english teen holds
on to firecracker for too long
platypus eating from hand and getting
belly rubs
[Laughter]
aren't you horrifically poisonous isn't
that dangerous for the person
like aren't platypi extremely poisonous
but look at the little tits
oh that's so cute whoa this
one what is this this title is just
what is this grandma is set on fire on
her
birthday that's such a horrible sentence
on her birthday grandma's birthday or
baby panda trying to escape
i'm guessing that means escape grandma
no
no okay that's enough of that don't
spray silly string around fire
it's so flammable i wanted a baby panda
trying to escape
okay old man plays beautiful rendition
of somewhere over the rainbow on a saw
or aftermath of circular saw accident
oh please i just want to hear over the
[Music]
rainbow
that's so nice
that's nice that's so nice
oh that's nice oh that's real nice
oh that's real nice oh that's nice
all right that was nice that was totally
worth it i'm so glad that i risked my
sanity for seeing that
that was great all right man falls off
motorcycle
or a man does cool vape bubble trick
let's go
it's a bubble trick vape me
vape it up wow
wow wow wow
wow i don't like this i don't like this
whole phrase
cute girl being poopy
what does that mean cute girl finds a
puppy or
cute girl being poopy what kind of even
sentence is that
what what phrase what universe is that
is that an apt description of what's
happening in that content
oh
i know what they mean now by cute girl
being poopy
uh okay
i'm not sure what this even means lion
cub hugging mom
or anime spider tooth vagina spitting
webs
now i've seen a few animes in my time
i have no idea what that might be
but i completely believe that it exists
[Laughter]
thank goodness
like a horrible mixture of the two this
is just
lovely i like that that's
good okay what is this we've got toto
africa vocals one step out of key and
off beat
or toto by africa or africa by toto
all right sounds like africa
i mean tonight is
[Laughter]
[Music]
is
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my god
okay that's i can't i can't do that
you know it's bad when me trying to read
this in my head doesn't make any logical
sense
dude puking blood into an empty skull
and drinking it again
all while wearing an octopus on his head
or how a liquid behaves when existing in
all three phases
at once now me a science buff i think
that'd be cool to see i don't know why a
dude is puking blood into an empty skull
and drinking again all while wearing an
octopus on his head but
here we go
why where did you get that octopus oh my
god
i'm just why why why does that exist
what what that looks professionally shot
is there a way that i can get the other
one because i'm actually curious
oh yeah look i got the other one now
what is this oh
i don't know what's happening whoa
that's so cool what is that okay well
that was
that was fun all right let's keep going
i guess some of these
uh some of these i intentionally avoid
and it'll be pretty obvious
why because i'm not here for porn and
i don't want to see the alternative so
if it's something like girl with
humongous hungalanga nonologus or
sliced up penis i'm just gonna skate
right by cause i don't need none of that
that is okay
uh how about this one police dog give
cpr
or women angry over lack of cheese
they both say safe for work
was it police dog giving cpr
that's such a good dog that's a i love
the little light on the back that's such
a good
dog oh you're such a good dog
you did it i love the light you need the
light
you need a wee woo oh that was so good
i don't know what the angry women over
cheese thing was
oh oh no
oh i have a funny feeling this ain't
going to be worth it
aftermath of man mauled by bear or
my cat in a blanket
[Music]
he's like oh my god i'm so relieved
this is like the pure adrenaline from oh
my god i don't want to see it
oh it's just a cat it's just a cat oh
it's just a cat
oh it's so nice oh it's so nice it's so
nice
oh it's so nice oh boy all right
saxophone
saxophone another music one saxophone
quartet plays the me channel theme
or horrible recorder cover of the me
channel theme let's go for it baby
[Music]
ah that oh yeah that's
nice
[Music]
yeah that's that's real good thank you
okay i'm done thank you that was great
thank you
thank you thank you how about this one
cute fluffy doggy smiles at the camera
or guy collects public used property as
part of his fetish
and becomes one with it
what kind of fetish requires you to
become one with public use property
i guess i'm going to find out
[Music]
no no no no no no
no
he was collecting poop he was collecting
poop
he was collecting oh
just want a happy one you know i was
just like a happy one
gangrene foot or small puppy i'll take
the small puppy please
please can i have the small puppy can i
get this
that's nice that's good okay thank you
thank you i need it it's so bad it's
really badly
it's a tiny adorable puppy and i love it
i love it forever and i love it and i
love it and i love it so i'm gonna end
that there
that is reddish 5050 challenge if you
want to go down
the rabbit hole of this horrible
horrible horrible subreddit
feel free i'll put a link in the
description you can turn not safe for
work off but there are fewer submissions
obviously but you know hey you know
pick and choose at your own risk see
what's worth it
try to have fun and thank you everybody
so much for watching
thank you for subjecting yourself to
this with me or just watching me
subjecting myself to horrible stuff
i mean obviously i censored that stuff
but
this is why it took over a year to do it
again yeah anyway but thank you
everybody so much for watching i hope
you guys enjoyed this
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below oh man
and uh thanks again for watching oh and
uh just fyi
if you're looking to support the channel
it's no longer called sponsorships
they're now called channel memberships
the big sponsor button
has changed to a join button that's what
that all is so
if there was any confusion hope that
cleared it up thank you again everybody
so much for being here
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye